Behold, this infinite
mathematical universe...
a dizzying cascade of fractals.
Arrays of complex patterns filled with both
satisfying self-similarity
and surprising, novel features.
All of the structure and the patterns
that you see there really do exist for a reason.
There is some sort of innate mathematical
cause behind all of the phenomenon
that you see.
This is the Mandelbrot set.
These trippy images represent a form
of modern algorithmic exploration,
one made possible by computers.
A handful of mathematicians have devoted
their lives to uncovering this set's secrets.
It plays this very central role
in our understanding of much,
much, more complicated systems.
It is step number one.
And we may be on the verge
of finally understanding it.
So what exactly is the Mandelbrot
set and how does it work?
The Mandelbrot set is a perfect example
of how a simple rule can produce
incredible complexity.
At its core,
the set is generated by
iterating a quadratic equation,
a simple formula whose
highest exponent is two.
To iterate a quadratic equation,
choose a value for the variable,
plug it into the function,
then take the output and feed
it back in again and again.
The study of how recursive functions like
these change over time is central to a
field of math called
Complex Dynamical Systems.
This subject came about with the
goal of understanding the real world.
What are the mathematics that underlie
the physical world that we see?
Most important early example
would've been the solar system.
So dynamical systems that you have some
space where you have some rule that's
assigning as time moves on,
how that space evolves and
how things move and change.
In the early 20th century, mathematicians,
Pierre Fatou and Gaston Julia set
the stage for the discovery of the
Mandelbrot set with their
exploration of dynamical systems.
To investigate these dynamical systems,
mathematicians study intricate shapes.
today known as Julia Sets,
Julis sets are produced by iterating
a function of complex numbers.
A complex number is defined
as the sum of two components,
a real part and an imaginary part.
Each complex number can be
visualized as a point in a 2D plane.
The real part is a number
found on the number line.
The imaginary part is a multiple
of the square root of negative one,
which mathematicians write
as 'i'.
Despite the name,
imaginary numbers play a vital role
in solving real world problems.
To construct a Julia set, start
with a simple quadratic equation.
F of Z equals Z squared plus C.
Choose a value for C like
negative one for example.
Then consider what happens when you
iterate this equation
for every possible starting value.
You repeatedly apply the function
to the sequence of numbers
that you're generating,
and you ask whether or not that sequence
is going off to infinity
or whether it stays bounded.
For some initial values, your
equation speeds off to infinity
when iterated like this.
These values are not in a Julia set.
When you start iterating
from other initial values,
you might instead get a sequence
of outputs that stay bounded.
When something comes back to itself,
often we call that recurrent behavior,
and that's where the complexity arises.
The boundary between points that stay
bounded and those that don't, is a Julia Set.
You can fill it in by
including all the bounded values.
Different quadratic equations generate
a wide range of filled Julia sets.
From basic blobs to intricate twisting tendrils.
Filled Juliia sets can
be divided into two categories.
Sets where you can draw a line from one
point to any other without lifting your
pen are connected.
Sets where points look like scattered pieces of dust
are disconnected.
The first rough plot of the Mandelbrot
set appeared in a 1978 paper by the
mathematicians Robert
Brooks and J. Peter Matelski.
Soon after Benoit Mandelbrot,
a researcher at IBM,
who had access to more computing
power, also discovered the set.
This led to further explorations.
These early computer graphics were crude,
but the patterns revealed the presence
of something far more complex.
Even with fuzzy,
poorly made pictures in the Eighties,
they were able to really glean a lot of
interesting insight into what's going on.
Mandelbrot went on to popularize
his now eponymous set to the world and
became known as the
father of fractals.
Today, mathematicians can use computers to
explore the Mandelbrot set in far greater detail.
As soon as you have images
just opens up this whole world.
The Mandelbrot set is
drawn in the complex plane.
It's constructed by iterating the same
quadratic equations used to produce
Julia sets. But here things are flipped around.
Instead of iterating all values
of Z for a fixed value of C,
we fix the starting value of
the iteration at zero and vary C.
Values of C,
where iterations of Z squared plus C
stay bounded are inside the Mandelbrot set.
While those that go to infinity are not.
Here, we can select points inside the Mandelbrot
set to reveal their corresponding
filled Julia sets.
The Mandelbrot set acts like an atlas,
cataloging the different
kinds of Julia sets.
Values of C inside the Mandelbrot set
are associated with connected Julia sets.
While values outside the set
correspond with disconnected dust.
The Mandelbrot set has
many intriguing features,
but its biggest mysteries lie
in its complex fractal boundary.
Zooming in to different boundary regions
reveals some astounding features.
A valley of seahorses,
parades of elephants and miniature
versions of the set itself.
So we can sort of keep finding nests, a
sequence of smaller and smaller Mandelbrot sets
sets, all one inside of the next.
Here at the boundary, mathematicians
are probing for answers.
As you look at it, it sort of seems
like one blob, but if you really ask,
is it all connected? Or maybe
if I zoom in far enough,
there's some separating piece.
This question is central to a 40-year-old
problem
called the Mandelbrot Locally Connected Conjecture
or MLC.
If the set is locally connected,
that means that no matter what point you
choose to examine or how far you zoom in,
the area will always look
like one nice connected section.
For example, if we
closely examine a circle,
we can see that it's locally
connected at every point,
but take a fine-toothed comb and zoom in.
While the comb is one connected shape,
at close range, it can look disconnected.
If mathematicians can
prove that MLC is true,
then a complete understanding of the
Mandelbrot set would be within reach.
This local connectivity question, if
we can answer it, if it can be solved,
this will give us almost complete control
and understanding of what's going on.
The hope is that once we completely
understand quadratic polynomials
we can go on to looking at more complicated dynamical
systems
and be able to describe them more and more.
But a full understanding of the
Mandelbrot set wouldn't put an end to our
collective fascination
with this famous fractal.
Hard to imagine that it wouldn't
be interesting to people,
even if we fully understood it,
because it is so complicated
and so rich and so beautiful.